[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
SACHA JENKINS: Hello,
everyone at Google and people
who are googling in the
world somewhere vast.
My name is Sacha
Jenkins, and I am here
with this gentleman
here who is from Queens.
Went to the same--
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
We went to the same lackluster
junior high school in Queens.
And for me it's really
powerful to see him
and the success he has.
And I told him recently--I had
the good fortune of seeing him
perform at the Kennedy Center,
which I'll talk about later.
But when he was on stage in
front of a 80-piece orchestra
performing these songs
that you guys are here
to celebrate and
learn about, it was--
I had flashbacks of my
junior high school stage
that he attended.
And to see him at
the Kennedy Center
really says a lot not only
about where hip-hop has come,
but where Nas has come
from, and where he is,
and it's a real testament
to why we're all here today.
So give the brother
another round of applause.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
Who let the dogs out?
[LAUGHTER]
So I was joking
with him backstage.
I mean, I'm looking down now.
My man has Timbos.
And I said to him, it
feels like in '94, he
did an amazing front flip
and landed on his feet.
And here we are in 2014 and
it's like he did a back flip
and landed on his feet.
And I've been sort of
loosely in the music
business for some years writing
about it, producing things
relative to music.
And I've never seen an album
that is 20 years old still have
such a frenzied interest coming
from so many different people.
I was saying to him
how does it feel?
It's almost like this "Illmatic"
is a brand new record in 2014.
NAS: Well, I'm happy
that you are here.
And today feels like
1994, and what I mean
is it feels like a whole
new beginning for me.That's
just my little way of
looking at things today
because of reissue
of the record.
So it takes me back.
SACHA JENKINS: It
takes you back how?
NAS: Like just
the people who was
around me making this record--
I think about them-- the people
who were in the studio with
me, hanging out with me,
listening to the record,
the works in progress,
and telling me their opinions
while I'm working on the songs.
It takes me back
to riding around
with no license in Harlem,
and Brooklyn, and the Bronx
in my first car-- Lexus
GS300, and no license.
And excited it had
a Nakamichi system,
and it came with the car.
And it was just like
going in from hanging
in my boys' cars listening to
the songs as I was making them.
And then when it was done, and
then getting my own first car,
and then riding in
that with my boys,
and just going all the
way around New York.
And it just brings me
back to those fun times.
SACHA JENKINS: Eating Chinese
food, Harry's chicken wings--
NAS: When I got my first car,
I still had the Chinese food,
but I ate better Chinese food.
SACHA JENKINS: Nice.
NAS: Yeah.
SACHA JENKINS: I've been
thinking about it a bit.
And, again, having this
conversation about front
flips and back flips--
and we have microphones.
At some point, people can
weigh in, specifically
on "Illmatic"-related
questions--
but it feels like because the
climate in hip-hop has changed
so much and that intelligence
is actually valued,
it feels like that's why
Nas' work, why "Illmatic"
is still uber-relevant
today because of the level
of intelligence and
thoughtfulness that he put
into his lyrics,
and his delivery,
and the music that supported it.
To me, it feels like
hip-hop, in general, now,
and the people who
create hip-hop,
and the culture around
hip-hop, and the culture
that hip-hop fuels,
intelligence is
something that's really valued.
Where when you came out,
you were a real jewel,
and you still are,
but now it feels
like we're encouraging more
young people to be intelligent.
NAS: Yeah.
I get with that.
If you think about
Kendrick Lamar, where
he's at with his lyrics-- and
you know that this kid's got
some sense.
You know he's got
something to say.
You know he knows how
to tell his story.
He's clear about
his perspective,
and he still flows
like an animal.
So same as SchoolBoy Q,
and the rest of the guys
you guys have on the
film-- Tech N9ne, Jay Rock.
You can tell
they're street guys,
but these are the guys
that got some sense.
And I love it because the guys
before me had a lot to give.
You know what I mean?
And so I took from that,
and then I give it out,
and then it just keeps going.
SACHA JENKINS: Well,
talk a little bit
about some of the guys
who had a lot to give.
Personally, I'm from Astoria.
I take pride in Super
Lover Cee and Casanova Rud.
And I threw that
out at you because I
hear a little bit of
that influence in there.
Can you talk about
some of the people
who have helped create this
miraculous flow that you have?
NAS: Man, I mean it's just like
you're listening to these guys,
and you're thinking to
yourself it's magic.
These guys have this magical
gift to do what they're doing.
And you want to do it.
The guys you just mentioned,
Super Lover Cee, Casanova Rud,
MC Shan, Chuck D, Rakim,
Kool G Rap, Kane--
there's so many guys
that opened my head up
about a lot of things.
So I knew that if
I got into rap,
I wouldn't be accepted unless
my presentation, my first record
was accepted by those guys.
So I had that in mind
when I made the record
that Kool G Rap had to
love it, or else I failed.
SACHA JENKINS: Well, talk
about that because you
are from Queensbridge,
which many people think
is an actual town when it's
an actual housing project.
And it is a town
in itself in that
its own community
center, and supermarket,
et cetera, et cetera.
But it was also home to so
many really important MCs.
It was the home of Marley Marl.
So when you say stuff like "Kool
G Rap really had to like it,"
you could have run
into him at the bodega.
Talk about that sort of
legacy of where you came from,
and how that really
pushed you or inspired
you to do what you
wound up doing.
NAS: Yeah, so I had my heroes.
I'd go to the record store
when they had record stores
and buy these guys' 12"
singles and buy their albums.
And then I would see them
because, like Sacha said,
DJ Marley Marl, who's
a hip-hop pioneer
producer from my
neighborhood, was
the guy behind the
production from Biz Markie
to Big Daddy Kane, Roxanne
Shante, the Juice Crew.
And I would see Kool G
Rap signing autographs,
or MC Shan shooting a video
on the hill on the projects,
or just see MC Shan
washing his Audi.
And it made me feel
like, I'm in the place.
I'm in the right place.
I'm around this
energy right here
that is going to
pass through me.
And at some point, it's going
to be my turn at the stage.
And when I get there,
I've got to do it right.
You know what I mean?
So I saw a lot of
good in those guys.
And I saw their mistakes--
the chinks in the armor.
Their mistakes
were lessons for me
when I saw their careers
start to decline,
or I saw an artist messing
with drugs too much.
And anything that was
not good for his career,
I saw it mess them up.
So, for me, I said
I don't want that.
I don't want to be a
rap star where they're
going to watch
you, and judge you,
and the slightest thing
you do, you fell off.
I said the way I want
to approach music
is going to be
just the way I am.
It's going to be
the Timberlands.
It's going to be the Army
jackets, just the way
we are outside.
I wanted to put that into
the record from the package
into the songs.
So that was how I was different
from the guys before me.
They were great, amazing guys.
So I had to tell a
story that was my own.
I couldn't be Kool
G Rap, and Eric B,
and Rakim, and Big Daddy
Kane because these guys were
superstars with the big
chains and the Rolls-Royces.
And that didn't come
until later for me.
But, yeah, my
approach was to talk
about that kid on the corner.
I wanted that kid
who wasn't on stage.
I wanted the stage to
come to him on the block.
SACHA JENKINS: But before
you became famous, before,
like today, he's like the
number one trending topic
on Twitter and all that, you
had infamy in the projects.
That was probably your
first taste of yo,
little man is nice.
Like is there a poignant
moment you remember
where you were at the bodega, at
the laundromat, whatever, just
walking around, and just hearing
like people buzzing about you?
Because this is before records.
This is when there's [INAUDIBLE]
on 12th Street or whatever.
And people just
knew you were nice.
NAS: It was a small group
that really knew I rhymed.
I never really let
everybody know.
I wasn't the outgoing guy.
I wasn't yelling.
I wasn't looking for attention.
I used to watch all of
the other guys do it,
and I didn't know where
they were headed with that.
And I'm like OK, it's
going to burn out.
It's like I was more to myself.
So when it did get out there
that I rapped-- when it really
got out there was like 1991
when "Live at the Barbeque"
came out with Main Source.
That's when the neighborhood
knew that I rapped.
SACHA JENKINS: So do you
remember the first time
hearing it on the radio?
Or what was a
poignant moment when
you felt "Live at the
Barbeque" is popping,
like, I might have a chance?
Things are starting to move.
NAS: Yeah, I was walking
through my neighborhood.
And I couldn't find none
of my friends one night.
So I just went walking
up the hill and down.
I seen a bunch of the older guys
together, hanging out, talking.
There was a car, music
blasting from the car.
It was a radio-- late.
And they were older than me, but
I didn't know where else to go
hang out.
I was bored, so I just kind of
hung out where they were at.
And then the song came on,
"Live at the Barbeque."
At first I thought
I was tripping.
And then I'm like
it's really coming on.
The song really came on.
And these guys are
having a good time.
They're talking
amongst themselves.
Well, they're loud.
And I'm trying to
get one of them
to notice this is
me on the radio.
[LAUGHTER]
And they didn't even
listen to me, man.
They were so caught up, so
I just blocked them out.
And then I'm just there sitting
and hearing myself, just
smiling to myself,
and I walked away.
And I probably got home
and made some phone calls.
SACHA JENKINS: Did you have
a beeper at that point?
NAS: Yeah.
SACHA JENKINS: All right.
[LAUGHTER]
So you'd call people, you missed
them, and then they beeped you.
You said all right,
son, I'll try
answering machines
and stuff like that?
NAS: Something like that.
SACHA JENKINS: The album
is such a rich portrait
of what your life
was in the projects.
And people in Australia,
people in New Zealand,
people in Switzerland now
know what Queensbridge
is, or know what
your experience was.
But while there's this great
fascination with projects
and project life,
sometimes it feels
like people who were
from the outside
have like a one-dimensional
kind of perspective
on what project life is.
Can you just tell
us the full scope
of the people who
live in the projects?
It's not just crackheads, and
crack dealers, and rappers.
NAS: Right.
Right.
There's other people, too.
[LAUGHTER]
Especially, coming out of
the '80s into the '90s,
the '80s was so much fun
for me and the '90s, too.
I mean, as a neighborhood,
as a community,
you learned to
protect your community
by the older people that were
out there when you were a kid.
If you were coming
from a neighborhood,
you were a little bit too far
away from your neighborhood,
it'd get a little sketchy.
And people notice you're
not from out there.
Next day you know,
you're getting chased.
So it felt good to
get closer and closer
back to your neighborhood.
Then you see somebody
that can go call somebody.
Yo!
Somebody's after
my man over there.
So-- man, where was I?
SACHA JENKINS: Talking
about community.
NAS: Community,
community, community.
So that sense of
community is so important
because you've got
all these families,
and you grew up
around each other.
We played football together.
We played basketball together.
We'd joke on each other.
Holidays, whatever-- it's
just this great community,
and we spent a lot of
time with each other,
and it becomes like a family.
And that was a real
good side of it.
You always hear-- I
remember I did VH1.
I didn't want to do
it "Behind the Music"
because I said please
don't narrow it down
to just me talking
like hood stuff.
You know what I'm saying?
Because then it makes it
the typical rap story,
crack dealing.
I walked outside, and it
was this, and it was that.
But it's hard not
to tell that story
because people need
to hear those truths.
They need to hear what was
going on across the bridge
from Madison Avenue.
They need to hear the truth.
They need to hear the
ugly side because that's
how we fix the future.
You can't ignore it.
You can't sweep it under the rug
and let this injustice happen
in this great city right here.
So I became a voice.
Yeah, there's nice
things going on,
but I had to let you know what
I was going through as a kid.
So it was a balance.
It was, I guess survival.
It was survival.
I walked outside one morning,
and I heard some shots
and seen some guys running and
pointing guns at each other.
And a young girl was
coming out of her building.
And I must have been
about 15 years old.
She was probably 13, and she
had got shot in her stomach.
And it just missed me.
And she was the nicest girl.
She went to my
elementary school before.
I knew her brother.
If they're listening
somewhere out there.
Hi.
She's all right now.
But I remember that
as clear as day
like it was yesterday because
it could have been me.
And that would have changed my
life so much as that young kid.
And so here it is.
You're walking on this
thing's parallel-- there's
like nice people, nice
lives, nice jobs--
but yet, then
there's another side.
So I tried to mix that up.
I know you said talk
about project people.
I'm not an expert
on project people.
SACHA JENKINS: No, no, no.
But the diversity, you know.
There are grandmothers.
There are people
who drive the bus.
NAS: Right.
Right.
SACHA JENKINS:
Hardworking, real people.
NAS: Good people.
Yeah.
They helped shape me, too.
Absolutely.
SACHA JENKINS: So a
classic "Illmatic" line
is "The rap game reminds
me of the crack game."
So 20 years later with all this
experience, as a new artist
coming in at that
point, coming out
of this very heavy
experience, and now you're
brand new saying this
on your first record.
What was it that
made you feel that?
Because that was like
a very-- you felt that.
And I think that's why that line
resonates with so many people.
What was it?
NAS: It was because
as I was getting off
into the rap game,
the sheistiness,
the shrewd business, the
unloyal stuff, the fake stuff,
the snake stuff, the money
chase, it was really similar.
It was really similar.
So I never really
trusted anybody.
I never really trusted anybody
because I didn't trust me.
If I didn't know what I
was able to do to somebody
at any moment, then
what are they thinking?
So I knew that someone--
lawyers, whoever they was-- I
knew they was ice
me in a minute.
And I didn't trust any of them,
so I made that comparison.
SACHA JENKINS: In
hindsight in all that
you've learned 20 years
later, would you still
equate it to that?
NAS: No, it's not.
I don't even know what
the crack game is no more.
[LAUGHTER]
It's a whole
different thing today.
I mean, back then
it was really almost
like concentrated
areas were coming out
talking about [INAUDIBLE],
Queensbridge, [INAUDIBLE].
It's a global thing.
It's a global thing that where
everybody has their voice,
and you could be heard.
It's about expressing yourself.
You know what I'm saying?
If you're from Detroit, you've
got your story for Detroit
that we all need to hear.
So it's open now.
It's an open game.
Yeah.
SACHA JENKINS: So, speaking
of global and travel,
you were this kid
from Queensbridge.
"Rap game is like
the crack game."
You're going through
these experiences,
and eventually, you're touring.
You're seeing the world.
And you're seeing the effect
that the stuff that we
did as kids, that was just
a part of our communication
as young people
in New York City,
is now something that people
around the world have embraced.
Can you relate any stories of
being in Istanbul or somewhere
really far away and really
feeling like wow, this thing
that we did as kids has such
a profound effect on people
so far away, in your travels?
NAS: In the
beginning or overall?
SACHA JENKINS: Overall.
NAS: Yeah, hip-hop took
me all over the world,
places I never wanted to go.
[LAUGHTER]
Places I dreamed about going.
It took me all over.
And people love it.
It doesn't matter
where you're from.
They relate.
They know it's theirs.
They know that that
music represents them.
It's honest, for the most part.
Its origins, where
it comes from.
The foundation of
hip-hop is honest.
They know that.
They know it speaks for them.
It sounds like them no matter
what language or whatever.
It's our music.
It's the music of young
people-- people my age, too--
but young people,
they claimed it.
And I've been to New Zealand.
I've been to Nigeria.
I've been to Australia, Tokyo.
And everywhere there's
that same love.
It's that same-- they're
like purists, too.
It's like a family.
It's a big rap community.
And they're serious, and
they'll look you up and down
and try to look through you to
see if it's honest with you.
I've been to Tokyo
and seen fans look
at me like are you the truth?
Or are you over
here playing games?
I've been places where they
have that pure heart for it.
So it's everywhere.
SACHA JENKINS: One thing
Nas hasn't mentioned
in terms of his
business ventures
is he's marketing
this bottle that's
essentially a fountain of youth.
[CHUCKLING]
Because so many people have
been asking for the product
now that he's been out
promoting the record.
And front flips--
he looks the same.
Is it really him?
I'm the guy in Japan.
Are you real?
You know what I'm saying?
The guy looks the same.
What is your beauty regimen?
[LAUGHTER]
The streets want to know because
there are a lot of other guys
who are 40 with Timberlands
who look 48, 53.
You know what I'm talking about.
NAS: I don't know what
you're talking about.
[LAUGHTER]
SACHA JENKINS: All right.
Well, you can purchase
this very soon.
He doesn't want to give
out the ingredients.
It's all good.
That's how he makes money.
Colonel Sanders had
his chicken recipe.
He's got his beauty recipe.
So lyrics.
One of my favorite
lyrics, and it's
hard to even-- it's simple, yet
complex and almost like a math
puzzle that you can never solve.
Or it's the math puzzle
that you want to solve.
And you'll spend time-- I
spend time actually thinking
about the weight of this line.
And it is "I need a new
nigger for this black cloud
to follow."
NAS: "While it's over me, it's
too dark to see tomorrow."
SACHA JENKINS: Yes.
NAS: Mmm.
SACHA JENKINS: I mean, you
think about the weight of-- how
old were you when
you wrote that?
NAS: Oh, somewhere around 18.
SACHA JENKINS: I mean, that's
a very heavy-- you know,
people have different
feelings about the N-word.
Personally, I'm not
necessarily a fan of it,
but in the context of
where we come from,
and how we express ourselves,
it has its place and its value.
It's not for
everyone, as we know.
But the personification
of how you described
what you described,
to me, is heavy.
It's almost, on one
level, it's saying
that society has labeled
you a nigger, on one hand.
And you have this
black cloud over you
that makes it so hard for you
to see what the future is.
NAS: Right, and "I need a new
nigger for this black cloud
to follow" is almost
like a blues man
singing a song about
his life, and he's
older, a lot older than 18.
That's what strikes me
about lines like that.
Like why was I feeling like
that at such a young age?
Life hits you in different
ways, and you deal with it
in different ways.
I felt like I was speaking
for a lot of people
when I wrote that.
SACHA JENKINS: And now
that you look back on it,
do you have a better
understanding of why you were
in that place, or why
you felt that way?
NAS: I think I was born
with sort of a fast life
thing in my genes
because I felt like it
could be over any minute.
So go after it now.
There are no rules.
There's no rules because the
guys with the rules were slain.
The guys who played by
the rules got dealt with,
so there's no one to trust.
I lived in Queens.
I lived in-- it was getting hot.
So that's how I
felt like talking.
SACHA JENKINS: So speaking
of language and the N-word,
you performed at
the Kennedy Center.
And he's got this line,
"Kidnap the president's wife
without a plan."
I notice you didn't
kick that one in DC.
I guess that's smart.
You could've got
hemmed up behind that.
NAS: Right.
Right.
SACHA JENKINS: But it was
interesting to me, you sitting
back listening to you and
taking in the whole experience.
Like first of all, there
was an elder white woman
who was a [INAUDIBLE] who
was ushering people in.
And she was dancing
in the aisles.
And then there was one
kid in the front row who
stood up and was
pointing at this guy
and going line
for line with him.
And there were people who were
just into classical music.
It was such a broad range
of experiences in that room.
NAS: Yeah.
It was like--
SACHA JENKINS: Oh, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no.
NAS: OK.
SACHA JENKINS: So bringing
it back to-- I thought it was
interesting in that you let
the N-word rock in certain
instances, but
others you didn't.
Is that an extension of growth
from being a dad or an-- talk
about that.
NAS: Yeah, I mean I had
to say the records the way
I said them back
then, but because
of the orchestra
and the strings,
the music is real softer.
So now you hear me
1,000 times more
stronger because these
soft violins are playing.
And my language is harsh.
And in part of the show, I
said something about that.
I said back then, we were
more rebellious in our music.
Rebel music was the thing.
It was Public Enemy.
It was Ice Cube.
It was rage.
It was America's youth and rage.
And that was the most
talked-about rap.
It was these guys
with their outcries
about their conditions.
So that inspired me.
So my lyrics back
then were like that.
They were rebellious.
They were enraged.
They were lit.
The were lit on fire.
So I told the audience that's
why I'm cursing y'all out
to violins.
[LAUGHTER]
But musically, it took
me somewhere else.
It was really classy.
It was a beautiful
audience, very diverse.
And I couldn't imagine
what they were thinking
watching me play with this
mostly all-white orchestra who
probably doesn't listen to rap.
Turns out they
did listen to rap.
Turns out they were really cool
people, the National Symphony
Orchestra.
They were really
professional, really amazing.
And it kind of took me to
another place with music,
and what I can do with music.
SACHA JENKINS: Well,
the energy was great
because you can tell they
had never experienced
that kind of energy
in a live performance.
Another lyric--
these are the things
that just randomly pop in
my head during the day.
I'll be walking down the
street, and I'll say to myself,
"Understandable smooth shit
that murderers move with."
What are they moving with?
NAS: This music.
I said that "The thief's
theme-- play me a night,
they won't act right.
The fiend of
hip-hop got me stuck
like a crack pipe"
in those same lyrics.
So everything is
woven into the lyrics.
Everything I saw, everything I
was around became the material.
So yeah.
SACHA JENKINS: And the
producers on the album-- I mean,
that was another really
radical departure from what
was going on in hip-hop.
You had all these
amazing guys teaming up
to give you the best
to create something
that was so stand-out.
Tell the audience a bit
about how that came to be.
NAS: Well, mentioning Chuck
D, Public Enemy and Ice Cube,
they had their producers.
The Bomb Squad did Public Enemy.
Dr. Dre did NWA.
Sir Jinx then started
doing Ice Cube.
Everybody had their producer.
De La Soul was
produced by De La Soul.
A Tribe Called Quest was
produced by A Tribe Called
Quest.
Who was going to
produce me, right?
So I knew one producer,
Large Professor,
and he had relationships
with the rest of them.
I didn't want my record
that have one sound.
I was a big fan of all
these amazing guys.
So I needed them to
give me the music,
so I could say what
I needed to say.
And at first people
thought it wouldn't
happen because that wasn't
happening, especially
for new artists.
But I was lucky.
They were into
doing this record.
And I would tell people-- yeah,
so who's doing your record?
Oh, Pete Rock,
Q-Tip, DJ Premier.
And they'd look at me
like yeah, all right.
And I'm like nah, that's
who's doing the record.
So after a while,
that became the buzz.
Oh, you know who's
doing this man's record?
And the anticipation started
to grow because people couldn't
imagine what would this--
never heard a album by me--
what could this guy be
doing with these guys?
What is he doing?
And I knew I had them
because from that point, that
was already a thing
going around the music
industry is like, he's
working with these guys.
So I had the focus on
me from that point.
So very lucky, man--
don't underestimate luck.
I was lucky.
SACHA JENKINS: Humble
gentleman right here.
So are there beats that
these guys offered up
that you look back now like
damn, I should've spit on that.
That wound up getting farmed
out to other people, or--
NAS: No because every
track was specifically
for me, every track they did.
There was some beats
that Pete Rock gave me
that wound up on him and
CL Smooth's album later.
He just gave them to me
to see if I liked them
before they finished
their record.
And I don't even
know if he remembers.
But I remember when
his album came out
I was like oh, I had this beat.
I had that beat.
Nah, they made all
the beats for me.
The only thing is
when once I was done,
and Biggie went to
work with Premier.
And I went to see Premier.
And Premier played me
"Unbelievable" by Biggie.
I was so mad at Premier.
[LAUGHTER]
I was so mad, Bro-- yeah.
So, no, they took care of me.
SACHA JENKINS: After the
cycle of "Illmatic" happened,
you had done the
record, you had toured,
you had done everything.
And you were on the verge of
creating your next album that
was written, what was
running through your mind?
Like how did you feel
about where you were?
Were you still hungry?
Did you feel like
there are things
that you hadn't achieved
with the record?
What was your mind state before
getting into your next album?
NAS: Yeah, I felt there was
things I didn't achieve.
There was a lot of
new guys coming out
that was making a lot of
noise and made it real for me.
And then BIG went platinum, and
my record didn't even go gold.
Everyone talked about it,
but it didn't go gold.
BIG went platinum.
I saw a way to get to platinum.
I saw a way to beat
all the naysayers.
All of them said he
can't do it again.
He can't make a big record.
He can't make a top-40 record.
He can't get to that stage.
He can't get to MTV awards
or whatever was the place
to be when you were
supposed to make it.
They had doubts.
He's in the hood.
He's not thinking like that.
He can't do that.
So if I was to come
back, now there's
a Notorious BIG on the
scene, so you can't just
come back just OK.
You can't just come back,
and make your little record,
and that be it.
No, you had to come where
BIG was at, or go higher,
or you failed.
It wasn't like today.
If I didn't come out and
get a platinum record,
get a big record, get
MTV-- do those things--
I don't care what the rest
of the world would've said.
Biggie would've been
like you're done.
And I would've have
had to let it go.
That's how it was.
I would've been written in
history as the guy who failed.
And so those guys motivated me.
That's one thing I
miss about Biggie.
He was a class act,
but he pushed you.
And he wanted that top spot.
That was his spot.
So if you were
going for the top,
you were walking
in his territory.
Even though I was
out before him,
he came and took everything.
So--
SACHA JENKINS: Well,
you influenced him.
I mean, he had a baby
on his record as well.
NAS: Sure.
But he killed it.
He killed it.
So now forget what I did.
It's Biggie's world, so I
had to come back and show
the people who were watching
I'm still in the game.
SACHA JENKINS: So what
was the conversation like?
You run into Biggie, you guys
both have turkey sandwiches,
you're talking like
yo, this is nice.
I'm feeling it, but you know
I'm going to take you out, son.
What gave you that sort
of playful intensity?
You said he was a class act,
but was it things that he said
or he did?
I'm trying to put people
in that era of you guys.
NAS: It was little
subtle things like there
was Biggie without diamond
bracelets and pinkie rings,
and then there was Biggie with
the diamond bracelet and pinkie
ring, number one record.
Everyone's playing the
music out of their car.
Everybody loves him.
Everybody knows
the music outside
of a club, night
time, New York City.
I walk up there in between
second and first album,
and Biggie sees
me, and throws up
his hand with the boom diamond
bracelet, and goes like this.
[LAUGHTER]
And he goes "Survival of the
fit, only the strong survive."
That's all he had to say to me.
That's all he had to say.
Everybody that was
with me didn't even
hear it, just me and him.
That's all he had to say,
and I knew what to do.
SACHA JENKINS: Did he
say it with a smile,
with a serious look?
Did he blink?
How did Biggie do it?
NAS: All of that.
[LAUGHTER]
Smile, serious, everything.
SACHA JENKINS: Nice.
NAS: Yeah.
SACHA JENKINS: So we
have mics on both sides
if you guys want to throw out
some Illmatic-esque relevant
kinds of questions.
This is very Phil Donahue.
[CHUCKLING]
Bringing it back.
NAS: Yeah, you're taking
me back right here, man.
This is crazy.
SACHA JENKINS:
This guy thought he
was going to be in
a conference room.
He's like oh, this is
where it's happening?
Where is everybody at?
AUDIENCE: Hey Nas,
how's it going?
NAS: What's up?
AUDIENCE: Not too much.
Just, first off,
want to start out
and say thank you
for coming to Google.
You're one of my--
[APPLAUSE]
To me, "Illmatic" is one
of my top three rap albums
of all time, so
thank you for making
something that's so important.
NAS: Thank you, man.
AUDIENCE: So my
question is actually
off of one of your lines.
So say "I sip the Dom
P, watching Gandhi
until I'm charged, writing
in my book of rhymes,
all the words past the margin."
Then kind of
fast-forwarding, you also
had this song called
"Book of Rhymes."
I'm curious what's your
creative style been
like over the last 20 years?
"Street's Disciple"
came out 10 years ago.
Do you still carry around
a book of rhymes with you
everywhere that you go?
What is your outlook like now?
NAS: And you wanted
to say because I later
said about Gandhi--
you know what I mean?
On the "Book of
Rhymes," "Gandhi was
a fool, fight to the death--"
AUDIENCE: "Plights of conquest."
NAS: Yeah.
"Sip the Dom P, watching
Gandhi" is trippy, right?
Like I'm drinking
champagne watching
the guy who was
opposite of that, right,
who was totally against what the
champagne represents in a way,
right?
Capitalism, imperialism, right?
I'd be thinking
about some shit, man.
[LAUGHTER]
I tell you, I tell
you, I tell you.
No, I don't have book
of rhymes no more.
I don't, man.
I write down notes in
iPhone, and no books no more.
I wish I did.
That's a thing
that I really wish
I could have the patience for
is to keep books of rhymes,
but I feel like I'm cheating.
I feel like I'm preparing.
I don't like to prepare.
I don't want to think
about it anymore.
I take down my notes,
and I leave it there.
I don't touch it until
I get to the studio,
and then I go through it.
But I don't want to
prepare too much for songs.
That may hurt me.
That may be hurting me.
I'm not saying
that's good advice.
It's just how I do it.
Just what I do.
AUDIENCE: So when "The
Lost Tapes 2" comes out,
are you going to just take out
a bunch of notes from your phone
and just start reading
off different things?
NAS: If I do, you
gave me that idea.
[LAUGHTER]
SACHA JENKINS: He'll text
Gandhi and send him some stuff.
AUDIENCE: Once again, thank
you so much for coming here.
I wanted to sort of
ask about-- "Illmatic,"
I feel like there's a
lot of jazz influence.
And I know your father was
a jazz musician as well.
It's just a big
part of your music.
Could you talk about jazz
and other genres of music,
and how that influenced--
NAS: I used to hate jazz.
AUDIENCE: Really?
NAS: When I was a kid, I hated
it because-- no, no, no, no,
no.
That's too strong of a word.
I knew it was
older people music.
[LAUGHTER]
I knew that I'd get to it later,
like I didn't like squash.
I knew--
[LAUGHTER]
I knew later I would like it,
but what made me like jazz
sooner than I probably
normally would have, my pop.
He brought me to hang around
jazz guys, and hear them talk,
and just watch these dudes,
and him playing the music,
and him playing
the radio station.
I'd hear this old guy Wolfman
Jack come on the radio station
with his wild voice.
And another station is
just rock and everything.
And saw him absorb the
stuff that was on radio.
He didn't really rock with disco
and all the other stuff that
was happening.
He was really into
the other stuff.
So I appreciate
jazz now, love jazz.
I'm big on Miles
Davis, "Kind of Blue,"
John Coltrane, "A Love
Supreme," Art Blakey, Herbie.
You know what I'm saying?
So I'm big on jazz
now, and I'm glad I
had the early experience now.
I appreciate it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
NAS: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming in.
I have a two-part question.
The first part-- I thought
it was very interesting what
you were saying about Pete
Rock [INAUDIBLE] and so forth.
So I was wondering if you could
talk a bit about your workflow
with them.
Would Pete Rock basically
come up with a beat
and then-- I'm just
asking because "Illmatic"
is 40 minutes of incredibly
tight lyrics to beats.
And I'm just curious
how you managed
to make that work so damn well.
And the second question
is about your 2006 album,
"Hip Hop is Dead."
And basically looking
at "Illmatic" today,
and seeing how it's such
an important album when
we look back on the
contemporary history of hip-hop,
I was wondering
if you could just
talk about that 2006 album a
bit, and sampling techniques,
and so on and so forth.
NAS: Well, going
to Pete Rock-- man,
I was a lucky guy
at a lucky time
because I was at that point
where the next generation was
about to come on the scene.
So a lot of people
like "Illmatic,"
and a lot of
younger people might
want to know what's the
big deal about "Illmatic"?
It was a number of things.
It was one of the
first of its kind
to talk about life
and that matter
from hands-on letters
about guys in jail.
Your friends, you're
writing letters to them,
and them writing you back.
And, for that moment, there
wasn't a lot of that out.
You know what I'm saying?
Afterwards, a lot
of it happened.
And the direction of rap
music flowed in that era
in what Wu Tang was doing
and what BIG was doing.
And then everyone became focused
on representing that street
thing where you're
naming the street corner,
you're naming the lady that
lives upstairs, the real lady's
name.
You're putting your
daughter's name in the record.
You're putting real-life
experiences in the record,
not just talking about a
subject matter and nailing it,
but you're really
putting your life in it.
I came in with that.
Wu Tang came with that.
Biggie came with that.
So I was just a
part of that time.
That's one of the things
that makes it special.
Pete Rock was the newest
out of Q-Tip and Premier.
Gangsta had already been there.
Tribe had already been there.
Pete Rock and CL
Smooth-- he was producing
for Heavy D. He was the
guy behind the scenes,
but you knew he was good.
Now he was at the forefront
with his own group.
His records were out of here.
They were blowing up everywhere.
And to get him was not easy.
So the fact I got him--
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
tell him how
you made [INAUDIBLE] go back
and redo all those other songs.
[LAUGHTER]
NAS: I don't know.
I don't know.
But they believed in me.
They believed in hip-hop.
They believed in a new young
guy coming on the scene,
and they wanted to help me.
And I remember Pete Rock
put out "Down With the King"
with Run DMC, the remix for that
and then the "Shut 'em Down"
remix for Public Enemy.
I was like he's going
to give me a beat.
You know?
So I went after it,
and I had to nail it.
I couldn't play with his time.
I couldn't play with none
of those guys' times.
AUDIENCE: But they gave
you incredible beats.
And was there a back and
forth like hey, Pete Rock,
I'm looking for this vibe.
Can you do that for me?
NAS: I think in the
beginning I wanted something
like what he was
doing on his own,
but he didn't listen to me.
And he didn't have to.
He knew what I needed.
And he gave me "The
World Is Yours."
AUDIENCE: It surprises
me because the album
is so coherent in
terms of the vibe.
So I guess congratulations to
you for tying it all together.
NAS: All right.
Thanks, man.
I appreciate it.
AUDIENCE: Nas, a
big fan, and I think
that you guys spoke
about "Illmatic"
is timeless music,
whether it's 1994 or 2014.
And one of the things you
touched upon, it seemed like,
was that healthy competition.
So you spoke about
you and Biggie.
And I know on some
of your other albums
you had addressed
certain situations.
It didn't necessarily sound
like eating turkey sandwiches
together.
But I think my question is--
and just looking, again,
from '94 through today-- that
there were certain times where
there would be that
healthy competition, even
just within New York, even just
within Queensbridge, and where
certain people, you
would engage with.
And there would
be that, again, I
think bringing everybody's
game up a notch.
And then there would
be certain times
where there wouldn't
be that engagement.
And people might say
something you would ignore.
And I would love if you can
just shed any light into what
would say OK, this person,
I'm going to engage with them.
And then somebody like Cam'Ron
where there was that back
and forth from the
Power 105 interview.
And he had said "on
freestyles and songs,"
and it seemed you
had ignored that one.
So any insights into
the competition,
the healthy competition?
NAS: Yeah.
I had said something about
Cam that came out of nowhere.
I was just really
in a place where
I was trying to start
something with everybody.
I was upset at that point, a lot
of things in my personal life.
And I wasn't looking
for a response.
I knew there would
be responses, but I
was looking for what I
was going to do next.
I wasn't thinking about a
response to anybody else.
It was more like what was
I building myself up to do.
I was building myself up to
do something that was not me.
And so I didn't really
hear the responses.
The things I do respond
on were the things
that seemed like they
were supposed to happen,
not me calling somebody out
because I'm mad that day.
And it didn't come from any
place that was any good.
So any other thing
I would respond to
would be something that was
a lot heavier, a lot more
serious.
AUDIENCE: You got
them with "Ether."
SACHA JENKINS: OK.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank
you again for coming.
A couple of us at lunch were
talking about your visit today.
And we kind of started
talking about how
it seemed like more
hip-hop and rap artists
than any other musicians seemed
to be more entrepreneurial
and do things like
mentor other musicians.
Do you think that that's true?
And, if it is, why
do you think that is?
NAS: You said artists
today mentor other artists?
AUDIENCE: Oh, no.
We were talking about how it
seems like hip-hop and rap
artists were more
entrepreneurial and mentor
other artists and musicians
more than like other--
NAS: What's that?
SACHA JENKINS: Your man Boldy.
NAS: Oh, Boldy James
in the house, yeah.
Well--
AUDIENCE: We were kind
of trying to theorize
on why that seemed
to be the case.
Do you do think it is?
NAS: Rock stars don't
have to build businesses.
Rock stars are supposed
to be anti-establishment.
They're rebellious.
Their parents are usually white.
[LAUGHTER]
It seems like they
didn't have it too hard.
It's not always the case.
I'm not saying that.
I'm just saying it seems
like-- so it's cool
when the rock star
says fuck the system.
I'm not going to sell out.
I'm not going to do this.
They have the opportunity
to say yes or no
because they can just cut
their hair, put on a tie,
and walk in, and get a job.
Us, on the other end, we
know we're not walking in
to be CEOs, and that this time
frame-- when hip-hop first
started, it's talking
about unemployment.
It's talking about no education.
It's talking about drugs
and police brutality
with Melle Mel on the message.
So the full achievement of
somebody from that condition
to make it in America-- that
story of that kid who came up
single-parent household,
housing projects,
drops out of school maybe,
carries a gun maybe,
maybe breaks the law
here and there-- that guy
is doing that because
he feels like he's not
accepted in corporate America,
even if he has the credentials.
There's going to
be some bullshit
on his way up the ladder.
So it's so amazing to see
that guy with $100 million
because it's the proof
that America works.
It's the child of the slave
ancestry thing coming back
into the American dream.
And that story is scary,
triumphant, beautiful,
and scary again.
[LAUGHTER]
So while the rocker--
he says no, Mom.
I don't want the
meatloaf tonight.
I'm going to go rock out with my
guitar and shit, and fuck that.
You know, slapping the base,
man, slapping the base.
It's cool for him
to do that while we
do, oh, he don't want the job?
OK, let him play
the guitar, and I'm
going to sell him the guitars.
So it's the rap
game, crack game.
It's the hustle.
It's the hustle spirit
that once I get a foot in,
I've got to take it all.
We have more of a reason to
want to start businesses, make
our mommies proud and our
grandmas proud and show them
nothing could stop us.
America offered it to us.
It seemed like we was going off
course, derogatory language,
messed up words toward
women and stuff like that,
but then it made a right
turn right up the right way.
And that's how
beautiful America is.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SACHA JENKINS: Speaking of rap
game, I guess it's a wrap here,
but we have an amazing contest,
Nas, you're familiar with.
NAS: Yes.
SACHA JENKINS: And we're
running on massappeal.com
NAS: Massappeal.com for sure.
SACHA JENKINS: Wherein
folks have the opportunity
to submit their ideas
for videos that they'd
want to make for songs
off of "Illmatic,"
and people are making
submissions encouraging people
to do that.
NAS: That's incredible.
Who's idea was that?
SACHA JENKINS: Was it yours?
Somebody's.
NAS: Can't remember.
SACHA JENKINS: Someone
in Mass Appeal.
So are we showing that clip?
[INAUDIBLE]
We're going to show a
clip of actually something
that Nas thought
was interesting.
NAS: Yeah, yeah.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-"Represent" is the
soundtrack to a movie,
but not just any movie,
a very specific movie.
[INAUDIBLE] was perhaps
the most obscure sample
in hip-hop history.
It's using a 1924 soundtrack
to the silent film,
"The Thief of Baghdad."
Now the movie is based on
"1,001 Arabian Nights,"
a classic fairytale.
It tells the story of a thief
who takes what he wants.
That is, until one night
he comes across a sleeping
princess.
The story basically
revolves around him
trying to win the respect
of the [INAUDIBLE],
who is the princess's father.
And in the end, he liberates
the city and becomes a prince.
My idea for the
video for "Represent"
is to have a collaboration with
both Nas and Jason Goldwatch
where we take elements
of this 1924 silent film,
which is now fallen
into the public domain
and flip them visually
the way [INAUDIBLE]
did with the beat and kind
of retell the story of Nas'
experience in Queensbridge
through the lens
of "The Thief of Baghdad."
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
SACHA JENKINS: So that's
an example of someone
who is making a submission
at massappeal.com for the Nas
Represent Illmatic
Contest, and you
encourage all of your friends
in the world to participate.
NAS: Yep.
SACHA JENKINS: Yes.
NAS: So that what his
idea for Represent.
SACHA JENKINS: That's
his idea, yeah.
NAS: For a 20-year-old song,
and the sample is to a movie--
SACHA JENKINS: Yeah, the film
is so old, it's public domain.
So his idea was to sort
of incorporate the imagery
from this movie that you could
just jack all the images from.
And as you were saying,
that's reminiscent of what
we do with hip-hop.
You don't have to
clear those samples.
NAS: I like that.
SACHA JENKINS: Yeah.
Anyway, thank you all
for coming out and--
NAS: Thank you, man.
[APPLAUSE]
SACHA JENKINS: Go out and
buy seven copies of this.
[APPLAUSE]